by now you're likely familiar with the
idea that dna
deoxyribonucleic acid is the molecular
basis of inheritance you might also have
a sense that it is somehow involved with
chromosomes and in this video i want to
make sure we can connect the dots with
all of these concepts that we have when
we come to genetics what's a chromosome
how does it relate to dna how does that
relate to genes and then how do genes
and dna relate to proteins or other
things
well as you can see in this diagram from
the national human genome research
institute they're showing us a blown up
cell so this is the outer membrane of
the cell that you see right over here
and in here they are showing us the
nucleus of the cell
and inside the nucleus of eukaryotes you
have your dna
now the way that they have shown it the
dna all looks like these x's over here
now it's important to realize that dna
isn't always in this condensed
chromosome form when dna replicates it
is in its loose or uncondensed form when
it condenses maybe in preparation for
say mitosis then it takes on an x shape
but this x actually has two copies of
the same chromosome but while they are
connected consider that to be one
chromosome but then once they separate
say during mitosis then people would
consider it to be two chromosomes now if
we look at chromosomes under a
microscope you might see something like
this
as you notice they come in pairs and
this is actually what chromosomes would
look like for the human genome you have
23 pairs the way we know that this is a
biological male is by looking right over
here this short little chromosome right
over here that is the y chromosome and
you can see each of these pairs have
what are called homologous chromosomes
which we've talked about in other videos
but it's the view that these two
chromosomes code for the same genes but
they might have different versions of
the genes on them you get one of the
homologous pair from your female parent
and one of the homologous pair from your
male parent and we've gone into some
depth into other videos now it's hard to
see it at this resolution but in this
image each chromosome has been
replicated and is actually two copies
connected at the centromere if we were
to spread it out it would have that x
shape right over there
now the question is how does a
chromosome relate to dna and you can see
it in this broader diagram right over
here a chromosome is actually just a
very very long strand of dna that's all
wrapped up and there's some other
molecules and proteins that are involved
like histones like you see right over
here that help package the dna but
that's all a chromosome really is
in the entire human genome we have 3.2
billion
base pairs
in our dna just a reminder of base pair
you can view as each of the rungs of
this ladder
now those 3.2 billion base pairs they
are divided into these 46 chromosomes in
a complete human genome
so you're looking at the order of tens
to hundreds of millions of base pairs
per chromosome now you're probably
familiar with this idea that the genes
on the dna are actually what code for
protein and that is indeed the case if
you have a long strand of dna right over
here not all of it is protein coding but
you have protein coding genes on it and
if you look at the entire human genome
you're looking at about 20 000
plus
protein coding genes each of which has
made up an average of about 3 000 base
pairs but it can vary a lot depending on
the gene you're looking at and the way
that we go from these protein coding
genes which are really just sections of
the dna on these chromosomes two
proteins this idea is known as the
central dogma of biology or oftentimes
the central dogma of molecular biology
so this is a chain of dna in a protein
coding gene the process of transcription
is what takes us from one half of this
to an mrna strand which is you can view
as a cousin molecule of dna now
messenger rna in particular that then
goes to the ribosomes it goes outside of
the nucleus of the cell goes to the
ribosomes we talk about this in some
depth in other videos and then at the
ribosomes that information is used to
actually construct proteins out of amino
acids and then those proteins those
amino acids will interact with each
other and they'll form a shape of some
protein that is valuable in the human
body
now what's interesting is that even
though we most associate
dna with genes that code for proteins in
this way the reality is that only one to
two percent of dna
codes for proteins so a natural question
would be what is the other 98 to 99 of
dna doing and that's actually an active
area of research but we have some good
ideas we know that some of that dna
helps regulate the coding of other dna
what's interesting about the human
genome or actually the genome of any
organism is that nearly every cell in
the human body has this same set of
chromosomes has all of the information
necessary to code for all of the
proteins that any cell might need
exceptions are red blood cells which
lose their genetic material and gametes
sperm or egg cells which have half of
the genic material but almost every
other cell has all the genetic material
but obviously cells are different heart
cells are different than neurons which
are different than skin cells so a lot
of the other dna is part of the
regulatory mechanism of which genes to
express which genes should be coded into
proteins and which ones should not as we
have different types of cells doing
different things and so this is known as
differential gene expression and those
parts of the dna that aren't coding
directly for proteins we would call
those regulatory sections of dna now
there's other stretches of dna that
instead of producing mrna which then
gets translated into polypeptides it
could code for other types of rna which
we would call functional rna because
that type of rna is directly useful it
has a function it's not just
transmitting information for example you
have ribosomal rna which can be directly
transcribed from dna and it's used to
make up parts of the ribosome you might
have seen transfer rna when we learned
about translation they are also involved
in the construction of proteins so i
will leave you there hopefully this
connects the dots between the idea that
most of your cells in the human body and
we're talking about tens of trillions of
cells have the entire complement of 3.2
billion base pairs that are in these 46
chromosomes that are organized in 23
pairs that contain these 20 000 plus
genes which only make up one to two
percent of the base pairs the rest we're
still exploring but it can be involved
in functional rna and regulation which
helps different cells do different
things at different times